[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part 4 the metric tensor
our model is getting more and more
precise
we have built a coordinate system to
describe the position of objects
we have defined proper time in order to
interpret world lines
as movements through space-time
and we have obtained a fundamental
equation the geodesic equation
which predicts the trajectory of objects
as long as we know
the christopher symbols
however a problem remains although our
coordinates locate points
they do not give us any information
about the distances and
angles between them
indeed the intervals on the grid do not
represent the same distance
everywhere nor the same orientation and
this has to be taken into account
[Music]
to do this imagine two points on the
sheet
very close to each other knowing their
coordinates
we wish to express the distance between
these points
at first glance we could think of the
pythagorean theorem
calling dx0 and dx1 the differences in
coordinates between the two points
we might write the square of the
distance as the sum
of the squares of both sides
but the pythagorean theorem only applies
if the lines
form an orthonormal coordinate system
if the grid is stretched in some way or
if its axes are not perpendicular
the pythagorean theorem no longer works
and we have to find a more general
expression
which works regardless of the grid we
use
generally the square of the distance can
always be written
as a sum of all possible combinations of
two sides
multiplied by some numbers
these numbers depend directly on the
shape of the grid
in the special case where the lines form
squares of side 1
the coefficients are respectively 1 0
0 and 1 which brings us back to the
pythagorean theorem
[Music]
all these coefficients which multiply
each combination
can be brought together in a table with
one row and one column
for each coordinate
we call this object the metric tensor
it is represented as a table whose
components allow us to calculate small
distances
usually this table is called g and its
components are numbered by two indices
we can therefore write the square of the
distance which separates two points
as the sum of each component of this
table
multiplied by the corresponding
differences in the coordinates between
the points
[Music]
this formula in particular allows us to
express the norm
of the velocity vector to do this
we replace the coordinate differences by
the components of the vector
bearing in mind that the norm of the
velocity is always the speed of
light we can write a more precise
version of this equation
it is very important to understand that
the metric tensor is a fundamental tool
in the theory of general relativity
indeed before this point we only had
coordinates
abstract numbers mathematical
descriptions which
do not represent anything concrete
thanks to the metric tensor we can
transform these
abstract descriptions into real measures
of distances and angles
the metric tensor is the key allowing us
to relate
abstract numbers to physical geometry
finally let's remember the geodesic
equation
we saw previously that this equation
predicts the trajectory of an object
provided that we know the christopher
symbols
but so far nothing told us the value of
these symbols
and the equation was therefore
impossible to use
it turns out that this object the metric
tensor
will allow us to calculate the
christopher symbols
indeed we previously saw that the
christopher symbols describe how basis
vectors
vary along the grid but the basis
vectors are directly related to the
shape of the grid
and as we saw the shape of the grid is
expressed
through the metric tensor itself
by measuring how the metric tensor
varies along the grid
we can thus determine how the basis
vectors change
and therefore the christopher symbols
thanks to the metric tensor we can now
calculate the value of the symbols
and thus use our equation
when we perform this calculation which
uses the variation of the metric tensor
to express the christopher symbols
we obtain an expression which involves
derivatives
of the metric tensor because we look at
how it varies
along the grid but also its inverse
denoted with indices at the top which is
another table
quite hard to calculate
most of the time however this expression
can be simplified
by choosing an appropriate coordinate
system
in particular we can manage to choose a
grid whose axes are perpendicular to
each other
with such grid the expression of the
christopher symbols
is simplified as it no longer involves
the
inverse of the metric but only its
components
and their derivatives
supposing that we know the metric tensor
we can now calculate the christopher
symbols
and using them in the geodesic equation
we are able to predict the trajectories
of objects in the universe
basically we have a method to describe
the movement of a free
body depending only on the geometry of
space-time
the geometry of space-time is embodied
by the metric tensor
which alone describes the relationships
between real distances
and our coordinates
unfortunately we still lack a method to
determine the metric tensor
in the next videos we will see how to
relate the metric tensor
to the curvature and the energy content
of space-time
as usual let's summarize all these
concepts with a concrete example
to begin with we take the example of the
earth
described by coordinates of latitude and
longitude
on the surface of a sphere with respect
to this grid
the metric tensor can be expressed as
the following table
the letter r stands for the radius of
the planet
and the angles theta and phi are the
coordinates of latitude and longitude
this general expression allows us to
calculate the metric tensor at any point
along the sphere wherever we need to
calculate it
we just replace theta by the
corresponding latitude
and if we want to measure small
distances around this point
we only need to sum each component of
the table
multiplied by the differences in the
coordinates
this sum gives us the value of the
square of the distance
between the two points
that being said the metric tensor only
gives us access to very small distances
if we want to measure a large distance
we have to calculate it
all along the trajectory because the
shape of the grid might change
from one point to the other in
mathematical terms this is called an
integral
a sum over an infinite number of very
small distances
the metric tensor is an extremely
powerful tool
from abstract descriptions namely
coordinates
it allows us to measure real physical
distances
on the surface of the sphere
finally we will at last apply these
notions to a real space time
we look at the simplest example an empty
space time in which an object moves
we imagine for instance a satellite lost
in outer space
to describe its trajectory we provide
our space time with two coordinates
time t measured on our clock
and space x which measures the position
of the satellite along an axis
as its proper time passes the satellite
will evolve
along these two coordinates
in such an empty space time the metric
tensor takes the following form
this metric tensor is quite simple
especially since it does not depend on
the coordinates
it is the same everywhere on the grid
and because it does not vary on the grid
all its derivatives
are zero and therefore all the
christopher symbols
are also zero injecting them in the
geodesic equation
this simply tells us that the components
of the velocity of the satellite
do not vary the satellite traces a
straight line
through our coordinates
this particular metric which describes
an empty space-time
is called the minkowski metric
the minkowski metric describes the
space-time of special relativity
it is rather simple in that it does not
depend on the coordinates
this space time has the same geometry
everywhere on the grid
a first prediction that we make with
this metric is the phenomenon
of time dilation
to do this we remember our previous
equation which related the norm of the
velocity
to its components
using this equation for the satellite we
can express its
temporal speed as a function of its
spatial speed
this value is greater when the satellite
moves faster through space
this means that the faster the satellite
moves through space
the faster our time will pass compared
to
its proper time the faster an object
moves through
space the more its proper time slows
down
compared to our time
at first glance the minkowski metric may
seem rather simple
but it is actually very special because
the metric contains a negative one
this negative one is a strange and
fundamental property of our universe
it tells us that the dimensions of space
and time
are fundamentally different
let's take our satellite again and
measure the distance that separates it
from a point in the future
here for example two light seconds
if we shift this point in space we would
expect a greater distance
but because of this negative one in the
metric the distance
is actually smaller and the more the
point is offset in space
the more this distance decreases
when the point is placed diagonally that
is to say that it's separated from the
satellite by as much
space as time the distance between the
satellite and the point
is strangely zero
an object moving along this diagonal
would actually travel
no distance through space-time and its
proper time
the graduation along its trajectory
would not pass
this is more commonly called light
beyond this diagonal distances become
square roots of negative numbers they
are imaginary numbers
and the satellite will never be able to
reach such points
nothing moves faster than light
[Music]
you